a draft and your plan for 2719 is out  now and we want to hear what you think  we've reorganized the budget for our  capital works program so we can  prioritize the completion of several  major projects and prepare for future  development find out what's happening  with your rates on average rates  increases are lower than previously  indicated however there are some areas  that have experienced large games and  capital values or are undertaking major  water supply upgrade tell us how we're  tracking with the management of a  natural environment this encompasses our  waterways stormwater drains and ocean  outfall and have your say on whether our  district shops should have the option of  trading on Easter Sunday so let's talk  you can view the plan and make your  submission online or at any of our  service center visit whoa mikuni DDOT  govt tdot in this to find out more and  have your say